en 2002 bil keys vano fue violada en
grupo mientras estaba embarazada y vio
como 14 miembros de su familia eran
asesinados por una turba hindú durante
los disturbios anti musulmanes en el
estado de gujarat en india ahora los 11
condenados que cumplían cadena perpetua
por violación y asesinato han salido de
prisión lo que provocó manifestaciones
en todo el país con cientos de personas
protestando
la misoginia y el patriarcado han
crecido tanto y se han normalizado hasta
el punto de que ahora la violación es
normal para la gente si los condenados
salieron con la ciudad tan fácilmente
esto significa que la cultura de la
violación se está normalizando la
liberación de los violadores se produjo
después de que un panel del gobierno
estatal aprobara la solicitud de
remisión de los agresores después de
haber pasado unos 14 años en prisión el
caso de vano tiene su origen en un
sangriento periodo de violencia en
gujarat desencadenado por la muerte de
60 hindúes en un tren en llamas los
musulmanes fueron culpados del incendio
lo que desencadenó disturbios en todo el
país y dejó más de mil muertos en su
mayoría musulmanes esta es la salida de
los hombres bueno dijo que estaba
devastada hace dos días del trauma del
pasado volvió a invadirme cómo puede
acabar así la justicia para cualquier
mujer confiaba en el más alto tribunal
de nuestro país la liberación de estos
condenados me ha quitado la paz se ha
hecho tambalear mi fe en la justicia el
primer ministro narendra modi era el
máximo responsable del gobierno en ese
momento y fue criticado por no hacer lo
suficiente para evitar el derramamiento
de sangre más de 6000 activistas han
emitido una declaración en la que instan
al tribunal supremo a revocar la
libertad de los autores